this video is proudly sponsored by
squarespace it would have been nice if
during this video about my best ever
results i was in something approaching
my best ever shape unfortunately life
gets in the way i've had a rotten cold
the last two weeks so i've actually lost
some gains
but the fact remains that over the last
few weeks prior to the cold i was seeing
some pretty decent results and what was
cool is that these were very similar to
results i saw
about nine or ten months ago when i
actually gained quite a lot of muscle
improved my strength and skills all in a
short time frame and at the time i
didn't know what was causing it however
now i have a much better idea as to why
i saw those results and how can
replicate them in future and i'm not
saying this is definitely going to work
for you but i am saying you should
definitely give it a try
so it was a few months ago maybe nine
ten months ago that i noticed i was
getting these really impressive gains i
was getting a lot of size and a lot of
strength more so than i normally would
and in fact people on instagram and on
youtube were commenting about it saying
dude what you're doing differently and i
looked into a few things that could
possibly be i tried looking at my
magnesium supplement which i did think
helped me to gain some mass but i don't
think could have been entirely
responsible i looked into the creatine i
was using i was using a lot more
creatine at the time again i think
helpful but couldn't entirely explain it
and then i realized that it was probably
down to an experiment i've been running
at the time for a few months at that
point which was to train throughout the
day so not one big workout but rather
three or even four smaller workouts all
in the space of a single day i was doing
this to find out whether i could get
similar results to what i would normally
expect training just once a day but
actually the results exceeded my
expectations and it turned out i got far
superior results now some of you might
be thinking but mr bioneer i thought you
already trained throughout the day and
it's true i use what i call incidental
training where if i'm carrying shopping
i might do some shrugs or if i'm waiting
for the kettle to boil maybe i do some
grip trainer which i keep by my kettle
if i'm waiting a bus stop i'll do some
car phrases but that's a different thing
versus breaking my main workout into
three 10 15 or 20 minute chunks which is
what i've been doing lately now i do
still have these longer sessions when i
come and film but other than that this
has been the way i've been training now
of course gains can mean different
things to different people are you
talking about muscle gains here size or
strength or skills or cardio or weight
loss well as it happens i think that
splitting your workouts into lots of
smaller segments is actually beneficial
for all of those things so let me
explain so i think i've packed on more
size as a result of breaking my workouts
into smaller chunks and this works for a
number of reasons for example i might
take my push day and instead i'll just
do some quick exercises for my pecs some
quick exercises for my shoulders on a
separate occasion and then some quick
exercises for my triceps three separate
workouts instead of one long one this
first of all allows me to attack each
workout fresh full of energy so i'm not
tired from training my pecs meaning i
can go harder on my shoulders at the
same time each time i do that i'm
spiking my protein synthesis my hormone
response etc which means that i'm going
to be more anabolic throughout the day
and this is just a lot more similar to
the way that we would have trained you
know in the wild this kind of training
might also mean that you're getting more
blood supply more nutrients to the
muscle over and over again because you
keep sending blood that way this might
also strengthen your tendons and your
fascia your connective tissue connective
tissue hypertrophy is a really
underappreciated aspect of hypertrophy
connective tissue like fascia doesn't
just connect on either end or even just
wrap around your muscle it runs through
it and it breaks into segments your
muscle is 20 percent connective tissue
so if you build more connective tissue
you add more size at the same time
you're less likely to injure yourself
and you're much stronger on your list
the reasons that people might not have
so much success splitting their training
into smaller modules like this is that
they aren't going hard enough i think a
lot of people think oh it's just a small
little workout i'll just take it easy a
few reps here or maybe even that's the
usual place to go in the gym but there
they have the benefit of doing tons and
tons and just really
you know piling on the pressure onto
those muscle groups what we're looking
at here is efficiency really intense
training so an example is i like to do
three times 100 push-ups and three times
30 dips that's one
hypertrophy focused and strength
endurance focused way for me to train my
pecs my shoulders and my triceps that's
quite intense likewise doing maybe 50 or
100 kettlebell swings in one go that'll
get your heart rate up that'll build
your posterior chain so think of this in
terms of how efficiently you can feel
some kind of response it's not enough to
just go through the motions if you're
going to be doing shorter workouts you
need to learn to make the most of that
time and now let's take a moment to talk
about today's sponsor squarespace so
squarespace is a powerful online
platform for developing modern
attractive and professional websites
with zero coding necessary squarespace
makes this easy with a number of
features are you ready gated members
only content for easy revenue generation
member management inbuilt email
communications and audience insights
there's also a fully integrated
commenting system with threaded comments
replies and likes powerful blogging
tools for sharing content categorizing
posts scheduling publishing and more and
social media integration to display
posts from your social profiles directly
on your website or push social media
content automatically
and that's still not all there are also
powerful ecommerce capabilities with
additional third-party extensions
providing inventory management marketing
streamlined bookkeeping sales tax
reconciliation and filing and logistics
for shipping globally go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch bioneer
viewers can get 10 off the purchase of
their first website or domain by going
to squarespace.com forward slash bioneer
today
and now on with the show
when it comes to mobility of course it's
really hard to overdo this obviously you
can do but you don't really need to
worry about performing a few stretches
or some mobility drills multiple times a
day that's not going to lead to any
problems so you can even just do one
exercise at a time so for instance
whilst the kettle's boiling you might do
some shoulder openers using a door frame
or whilst the tv's on you might just get
into a nice deep resting squat there's
nothing to stop you from doing this
multiple times and that's a great way to
prevent your body from going to sleep
not only do you improve your mobility
just through repetition but you're also
going to be keeping yourself invigorated
the problem a lot of people have is not
knowing the difference between being
tired and being lethargic so you might
come home from a busy day and think
you're tired because you've worked
really hard well actually you're just
lethargic because you've been sat down
for so long and if you were to get up
and move just a little bit it doesn't
have to be something big then you might
feel a lot more energetic and therefore
able to train and just able to do all
the things that you want to be able to
do you'll just feel a whole lot better
and just like it's hard to overdo the
mobility training it's also hard to
overdo skills training and this of
course gives you the benefit of greasing
the groove basically this means that by
continuously rehearsing that movement
over and over again you're reinforcing
the neural pathways that you need to
make it happen and therefore you get
better quicker
when it comes to something like cardio
what you're trying to do here is
strengthen the heart you might be trying
to lose weight as well in terms of
weight loss splitting your training up
into smaller components makes a lot of
sense so instead of doing one 30 minute
run you might do three ten minute runs
what this is going to do is once again
ramp your heart rate up multiple times
throughout the day then there's the
epoch the post exercise oxygen
consumption that means you actually burn
more calories following a cardio workout
so if you're doing lots of little bits
of cardio you're constantly burning more
calories after those meaning you're
burning more calories total it's also
just much easier to go for a 10 minute
run maybe three times a week five times
a week instead of one fifty minute run
if eventually run everywhere i go
whether i'm going to the shops or
whether i need to pop into town i run
with my daughter and just constant
movement like this keeps my heart rate
up keeps me feeling energetic and burns
more calories because i haven't had as
long to just settle into this inactivity
[Music]
of course you guys know me my goal is to
train for everything and so the way i do
this is by dividing my mini workouts
into groups based on what i'm trying to
train so i call these modules so for
example my jump module consists of
kettlebell jump squats
then jump squats without the kettlebell
then i perform some atg split squats for
the mobility benefits
and then i do some calf raises so i've
grouped these things together based on
the result that i'm trying to get other
times i might group things together
based on hypertrophy or strength gains
for example the chest pecs routine that
i talked about earlier that's more for
strength endurance for the pecs as well
as a bit of hypertrophy
of course i've barely even touched on
the practical benefits of these smaller
workouts like i say there's far less of
a psychological barrier to training for
just a short amount of time it can fit
more easily into your day and if all the
activity you do in a day is just a 10
minute run then that's much better than
not having done any at all don't think
it has to be all or nothing just a
little bit of movement frequently is
fantastic that's not my main point i'm
not saying that you can train like this
and you'll get comparable results i'm
saying this might actually be how to get
superior results because of that spiked
protein synthesis because of the
increased energy of approaching every
workout with because of the
greasing the groove and because of the
space learning because you're constantly
increasing your calorie burn throughout
the day raising your heart rate
increasing your vigor moving more
staying more mobile all those things
mean i think the results you get from
this kind of training are actually
superior as long as you design these
modules in such a way as to be
efficient and to stimulate some kind of
response
so if you enjoyed today's video guys it
turned out to be a little bit of a
challenge to make in places the first
time went out it rained off and then on
the second day as you might have noticed
my drone got caught in a bush and then
fell in a river never even found the
drone so it never got a proper burial
then i had to just pretend like
everything was okay and finish the video
even though i could have cried and i
still could cry but i won't
but i could but i won't
but i could anyways bio drone 2 is on
the way today according to the amazon
app so all is good i hope you enjoyed
this video please let me know if
training throughout the day in shorter
burst is something that you guys have
tried doing and if so what were your
results and what tips do you have to
share with people if you like this kind
of training then check out my new ebook
and training program plus a video course
super functional training 2.0 and there
i'm adding a separate lesson that will
show you how to take that program and
break it down throughout the day and
that's going to be free for anyone who's
already bought super functional trading
2.0 it will be added to the lessons and
anyone who buys it now of course will
get that as well and with that you get a
massive ebook that goes into depth on
human performance as well as a training
program with a online video series
showing you how to perform every
exercise over two hours of video content
and this is designed to build multiple
aspects of human performance all at once
so strength size speed mobility even
brain function so if that's something
you find interesting if you enjoy the
content on this channel then please
check it out i'll leave a link in the
description down below and there's a
launch discount still on but it won't be
on for much longer so get it now if
you're interested if you enjoyed this
one then please leave a like in honor of
the bio drone one and subscribe that
would help me out immensely hit the bell
button for notifications and either way
i'll see you next time thanks so much
for watching guys
bye for now